en colère des centaines de jeunes ont
envahi les rues de baltimore après les
funérailles de freddy gré et s'en sont
pris aux policiers des pierres des
briques et des bouteilles leur ont été
lancés mais auto patrouille ont été
brûlés plusieurs policiers ont été
blessés certains ont des fractures le
d'entre eux est inconscient ces gens ne
sont rien moins que des criminels
affirme la police le banc témoin qui dit
notamment avoir été menacé par des gagne
des policiers ont été déployés partout
en ville pour contenir les manifestants
l'anti émeute a tenté de les disperser
en utilisant des gaz lacrymogènes et
plusieurs arrestations ont été
effectuées mais ça n'a pas empêché des
émeutiers de se livrer au pillage de
plusieurs commerces de la ville
cette pharmacie a aussi été incendiée
toute cette violence a éclaté après les
funérailles de fred y quelques milliers
de personnes se sont rassemblées dans
cette église pour rendre un dernier
hommage au jeune homme noir de 25 à mort
lorsqu'il était détenu par la police de
baltimore et elle espère que justice
sera faite
interpellé le 19 avril trading sûrs et a
été plaqué au sol et a subi des
fractures aux vertèbres cervicales il a
dû attendre de longues minutes avant
d'obtenir de l'aide médicale
malgré ses demandes répétées plusieurs
manifestations ont eu lieu depuis cette
intervention policière pour dénoncer la
mort d'un autre jeune noir américain
omet de la police six agents ont été
suspendus après les tragiques événements
et des enquêtes sont en cours pour faire
la lumière sur le drame
ici olivier bachand radio canada
montréal